so a few years ago I was doing stand-up
almost every night one night after I got
offstage
the manager of a comedy club came up to
me and asked do you want to host the
weekly show we decided to get lunch the
following week and work out the details
but on the day of I got a text I flag
red flag number two I plate Lee declined
but he was very insistent so I finally
gave in
so 7 p.m. rolls around and surprise
surprise this guy shows up at incredibly
formal wear very flowers keep in mind
that I look like I'm 50 red flag number
3 at which point I've got compelled to
tell him um I'm sorry if you got the
wrong impression but I have a boyfriend
cool all right let's go so we're at
dinner at this incredibly expensive
place in Hollywood and we're getting all
kinds of weird looks from people I can
hear the judgement in the air
and of course the rest of the night has
nothing to do with stand-up or me
hosting a weekly show or anything really
to do with the pretext for which he got
here wait it gets worse when the check
comes the waiter tells them hi Sarah
your card has been declined
so he's freaking out calling his bank
and the restaurant is slowly but surely
emptying and I tell him hey I can
totally pay for this it's on me you
can't pay for our first date and that's
how I got tricked into a date and for
the record I did end up paying the 200
dollar bill so the next time he texted
me I killed him just kidding
I'll see you next Monday maybe I'll tell
you about that time I got away with
murder
stay awesome Gotham